ha habido quienes han preguntado por qué
afirmamos que donald trans un hombre pro
negocios
[Música]
y al fin y al cabo lo que defiende es
bajar fuertemente los impuestos
especialmente aquellos que afectan más
directamente a las empresas pues bien
hoy vamos a tratar de sumergirnos un
poquito más en el programa de donald
trump y de sus ideas para dejar claro
porque su elección sería una catástrofe
para las empresas y la economía
norteamericana soy enrique couto y esto
es visual político
[Aplausos]
[Música]
donald trump se presenta como un hombre
de negocios sin embargo paradójicamente
su elección supondría toda una
catástrofe para las empresas americanas
hoy vamos a tratar de justificar esa
tesis con tres puntos principales el
primero de ellos los impuestos
[Música]
es verdad que señor trump propone una
bajada de impuestos es muy elevada de
hecho hay quienes cuantifican esta
bajada en impuestos en aproximadamente
un billón de dólares americanos es decir
dos veces todo el dinero que recauda los
diferentes gobiernos que en españa dos
veces todo lo que recaudan los
ayuntamientos las diputaciones las
autonomías y el estado central y sin
embargo los impuestos no lo son todo es
verdad tienes impuestos moderados ayudan
a las empresas en actividad económica
pero para favorecer la inversión en
crecimiento se requieren instituciones
creíbles una política macroeconómica
prudente una política de atracción de
inversiones una normativa que proteja la
propiedad privada y de otros muchos
factores
en definitiva instituciones fuertes eso
es lo que hace por ejemplo en dinamarca
sea mucho más rico que armenia y que
además sea más fácil hacer negocios en
dinamarca que en armenia aún cuando en
el segundo país los impuestos son más
bajos que mira marca
y además el señor donald trump nos habla
de cuánto bajar los impuestos pero no
nos dice nada del gasto y eeuu tiene un
déficit de aproximadamente 450 mil
millones de dólares esto es un déficit
equivalente a todos los impuestos que se
recaudan en españa'
pero el señor tram dice que no va a
bajar el gasto público por tanto una de
dos o nos está mintiendo o es un inepto
lo cierto es que para que exista una
política macroeconómica prudente y sea
creíble para los inversores y para las
empresas ésta tiene que ser seria
predecible y rigurosa y señor tram no
nos habla nada de esto
el segundo punto es la visión que el
señor donald trump tiene sobre la
globalización y el libre comercio
el señor télam es un nacionalista que
dice querer defender a la industria
norteamericana de la competencia
exterior
y lo quiere hacer por la fuerza mediante
decretazo estableciendo las reacciones a
las importaciones y lo cierto es que
esto ni es una política nueva ni nunca
ha tenido en el juicio ya se aplicó en
el pasado en eeuu y las consecuencias
fueron terroríficas en 1929 otro
republicano populista que había ganado
las elecciones también prometiendo
proteccionismo
herbert hoover comenzó a imponer los
primeros aranceles a los productos
alimentarios
y eso le siguió 1930 una gran ley para
establecer aranceles para prácticamente
proteger a toda la industria
norteamericana claro otros países
reaccionaron de la misma forma
establecen también sobre los aranceles y
lo que se generó un gran caos mundial el
comercio internacional se desplomó de
hecho las ventas de eeuu europa cayeron
más de un 50 por ciento y con eso se
terminó la especialización productiva de
cada país y que ocurrió pues que
proyectos empresariales quebraron muchas
fábricas cerraron y millones de obreros
estadounidenses perdieron su trabajo ese
fue el resultado de las políticas que
hoy defiende donald trump
y la realidad es que las consecuencias
serían aún peores porque hoy en la
producción global está mucho más
interconectado por ejemplo los productos
y consumos en el día a día lo habitual
es que han sido producido en muchos
países diferentes por ejemplo el ingreso
de como christie cada una de las
denuncias que hacen señor con otra y es
que las grandes compañías de coches a de
norteamericanos ha implantado sus
fábricas de san blas en mexico pero lo
que olvida es que el 40 por ciento de
los componentes de cada coche que es
méxico bien eeuu ha sido fabricado
previamente por obreros norteamérica
es decir si como quiere ser una trans en
ciencias en aranceles y se impidiese en
este reparto que favorece la
especialización productiva lo que nos
encontraríamos es con una menor
competitividad de la industria
norteamericana y con un menor poder
adquisitivo de los consumidores
norteamericanos en definitiva mal para
todos
en tercer lugar tenemos la obsesión del
señor donald trump con la inmigración
y como comentamos en vídeos presidente
es el señor trump quiere deportar a más
de 11 millones de personas y claro esto
tendría consecuencias en primer lugar
consecuencias en términos de coste y
competitividad para muchísimas
industrias de bajo valor añadido que lo
pasarían realmente mal por ejemplo quién
iba a recoger la fresa en california su
hija
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en segundo lugar consecuencias en
términos de demanda porque no podemos
obviar que estas 11 millones de personas
consumen y ahorran en los eeuu pero es
que además la inmigración tiene también
elementos la adición de valor que son
esenciales para toda economía siguiendo
el profesor hausmann y la teoría es
clave del desarrollo podemos decir que
los productos se forman con letras que
las letras son las capacidades
productivas de cada persona y que
cuantos más letras tengamos más palabras
complejas podemos fabricar es decir los
inmigrantes han tenido experiencias
distintas y por eso tienen unos ratios
de emprendimiento más elevados suelen
potenciar el comercio con sus países de
origen y además qué diantres impulsan la
creatividad y la innovación yahoo google
o amazon fueron puestas en marcha en
gran medida por inmigrantes por todo
ello por impuestos libre comercio e
inmigración decimos que señor donald
trump es un terror para las empresas
norteamericanas
[Música]